hello and welcome to this video its
Yardbird again and you get him at the
weirdest times of day they don't tell
you the time then I play this game but I
wouldn't have expected to play him yeah
the good old quadruple fianchetto of you
kiddo
okay I don't want to trade them no big
deal yeah this is opening is is very
very solid for black tough too tough to
get anything substantial with white or
anything at all for that matter he plays
it as usual super ambitiously with a
quick b5 and I have my doubts about it
so very early be five so let's see if
that helps them or beacon suspicion more
okay i just get fully centralized and
see what happens later gr 95 it's not so
effective here probably but yeah I guess
anyway there are some possible tactics
depending on what he does
and at night XD six if if he moves the
d7 light somewhere I mean ok let's seems
unlikely but still yeah okay this is
always possible bitten nothing that I
mind so much it's difficult for him to
play against that knight on d5 which is
the pretty annoying piece and tonight to
ma5 is also in this position yeah ok d 6
is very weak how would you see do that
if I take them let's just check this
first it's probably not that great right
now probably not i should just move the
night and you cannot defend these six
anyway so i'll go here and see what it
does out resign yeah nothing yeah d6
just just Falls with and this is also
coming up those very early resignation I
mean okay i think it's basically losing
but still yet d 5 96 and there's also an
IG for coming that's also not very
helpful yeah i think you just miss plate
that opening in some way ok b5 is super
ambitious I mean he s usually placed and
maybe it's good I don't know it seems
early to me but it is part of the
general let's say a strategic agenda of
black okay but here I felt my position
is ok I mean I'm very nicely centralized
yeah yeah it's not not easy for black to
handle this there's also Knight a5 that
could be could be annoying the computer
gives Queen a seven years
as more and wants to play like that
check yeah okay that's a little
something for white but nothing special
yeah okay I think the main issue is this
coming around here but it is already are
already awkward the computers best line
is already pretty bad this is what the
engine wants to do check and white has a
clear advantage with a pawn in the
better position and use exist isn't
working at all still I was a bit
surprised how quickly he resides here it
is it's it's not it's not fun some fun
okay a good win I think thanks for
watching